-Chelsea, you're known for
having strong opinions
about all different kinds
of things.
So with that in mind,
I'd like to play a game with you
called "Wheel of Opinions."
Here we go.
♪ -Wheel of Opinions ♪
-Thank you for always
playing something with us.
Here's how it works.
I'm going to hit this button,
which will activate
the opinion topic generator, and
it'll land on a random topic,
and whatever it is, you have to
give your opinion on it, okay?
Could be right or wrong, could
be short, long, here we go.
Ready? And now we go.
-Ooh.
-Alright, goatees. [ Laughs ]
-Goatees can go eff themselves
is where they can go.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness.
-It's out of style and they're
gross, so just stop it.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
You don't know anyone
that's ever -- No.
-It's not -- No, just stop it.
Either grow a beard --
Even a mustache is cooler
than a goatee.
A goatee is so uncool.
All it says to me is
that you're a Republican.
[ Audience ohs, laughs ]
-[ Laughing ] Let's get another
topic. Here we go.
-Ah! [ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God!
I'm sure you're gonna have
an opinion on this.
Legalizing mushrooms.
-Oh, yeah, my mushrooms are
just about to kick in.
I take mushrooms
almost every day.
I mean, microdosing mushrooms
is a game changer,
and psilocybin is
good for everybody.
It puts you in a good mood,
keeps you upbeat,
and makes you appreciate nature.
So yeah, legalizing mushrooms
for sure.
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
I know you know about that stuff
because I've seen the --
What was the ayahuasca one?
Is that mushrooms?
-Oh, yeah, ayahuasca.
Yeah, I'll do any drug.
[ Laughter ]
I'll try anything. For all of
humanity, give it to me first.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, here we go.
Chelsea, are you rubbing
your hands?
Or is there a dog?
-Oh, there is a dog.
[ Laughter ]
Did you think I --
[ Laughs ]
-I don't know what was --
You're going like...
You were getting into like
a dance routine for a second.
-Hold on.
Let me try and get him up here.
He's pretty big.
-Oh!
-[ Grunts ]
Pretty big?!
Oh my, Chelsea, be careful!
Oh, my God!
-Oh, Bert.
Say hi, Bertie. Say hi!
-Oh, my goodness.
Are you kidding me?
Look at that cute dog.
Hi, buddy.
-Oh, he's falling off now.
[ Laughter ]
That's my proof, you guys.
That's my proof!
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go.
Let's get another topic.
That was a great exit.
Here we go.
Okay.
-Frozen --
-Versus on the rocks margaritas.
-Well, you know what
I just want to say is,
you brought up mushrooms,
which I did just take some
right before our interview,
some chocolate mushrooms.
And I made myself a frozen mar--
well, no, a margarita
on the rocks
for our special interview,
so this is all coming together
very nicely.
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Applause ]
It's almost --
Oh, look, the dog's leaving.
Chelsea, I love you.
Thank you so much for coming on.
That is all the time we have
for "Wheel of Opinions."
My thanks to Chelsea Handler.
Her stand-up special,
"Chelsea Handler: Evolution,"
is streaming on HBO Max.
Check it out.